things can't go worse than that I'll
sleep on the floor I'll sleep on the
pavement I've never believed in super
stardom I believe that if people like
your work which is your performance in
front of the camera that is what
attracts them to you everyone said that
I was making the biggest mistake of my
life by going into television if things
happen according to how you wish that's
good but if they don't that's even
better there will always be somebody
who's going to be younger better than
you he's an Indian actor who's appeared
in over 180 films in a career that has
spanned over four decades he's widely
regarded as one of the most influential
and important figures in Indian cinema
history
he was so dominant over the Indian film
market in the 70s and 80s that people
called him a one-man industry he's
Amitabh Bachchan and here's my take on
his top 10 rules for success rule number
two is my personal favorite and I'm
curious if you grew up which one you
guys like the best and as always if you
hear something that really is motivating
and inspiring to you please leave it in
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired as
well
I doubt if there's any actor in the
entire world with all due respect to mr.
DeNiro when they haven't gone ahead and
done a film and it hasn't turned out to
be you know the the kind of film that
they they believed it would be or it has
been so incredibly bad that yeah it's
just kind of forgotten in their vision
sometimes you do films because we
believe in the person who is going to
make it sometimes it's a gesture
sometimes it's your own belief going
wrong we all make mistakes and if they
were mistakes fine but I will not derive
any film that I have done I will stay
with every film that I have made and I
will say that I had a great time making
them irrespective of what happened at
the box office the failures is a part of
every human beings life to think that
failures never ever going to come to you
is the first mistake it is bound to come
some point of time even if you're
writing a huge wave of success I think
it's it's important that at the back of
your mind you should be wary that
tomorrow everything can go wrong and
whenever I think like this I immediately
think okay suppose I was to lose
everything what is the bottom line that
would keep me comfortable so I go back
to where I was born and how I was
brought home in a Tonga wrapped in a
goodly and I say you know the worst is
that I can this things can't go worse
than that I'll sleep on the floor I'll
sleep on the pavement so you look at the
bottom line right that makes you feel
it's not and that's I think that's that
gives you feel that if you're prepared
for the worst you know a lot of people
can say look you know I can't do without
a house with 10 bedrooms or
I need two cars and I need a phone and
everyone has different priorities but I
think that what's really what I feel is
is that I think about the bottom line
and when it isn't too difficult to cope
with I feel very satisfied from there on
you say okay this is where I am I have
to move forward from it this is the
worst in it now I must move forward so
every day you keep begging away digging
at something poking at something and
even if it's a centimeter that you move
forward at least you move forward I'm
always reminded of an incident of my
father's we used to live in Delhi at
Willington Crescent which is near Teen
murti house where pundit used to stay
and at that time the diplomatic in
flavor which is now very very habitated
was just wilderness and wild jungle and
he used to go for his morning walk in
that region and used to leave at 3:00
4:00 in the morning and come back at
5:00 6:00 and he developed a taste for
looking at rocks on the road and finding
some kind of an image or a figure in it
and he would bring it home and with just
a stroke of a paintbrush you know bring
out that I mentioned you know or just
leave the stone like that and say look
this looks like a bird this looks like a
human and he developed this thing one
day he came back from his walk and he
woke me up as he normally would at 6:00
in the morning and say can you just help
me I've got something like which I
cannot lift so help me bring it in so I
went to the gate and there was a huge
boulder about this size and I said look
you can't possibly think that I can move
this so we called about 1020 people and
they pushed this huge boulder and
brought it into a veranda where he
wanted it to be put that done I asked
him look this is fine but how did this
come up to the gate she said you know I
I went from my walk I saw this huge rock
I saw this shape in it and I liked it I
wanted to move it
so every day I go I move it one inch and
I come back in three months it's landed
up at the gate so really it's a great
example that you know if you just keep
pushing something every day it may look
small but I think the important thing is
that you're moving forward and there is
some amount of satisfaction that you've
done something which is somewhere giving
you some satisfaction and that
eventually you will bring that huge
boulder to its this I've no believed in
superstardom I believe that if people
like your work which is your performance
in front of the camera that is what
attracts them to you I don't see any
other medium being used to attract
audiences it's eventually the film and
that's what's going to work you may have
the greatest managers and the greatest
PR machines and but unless you perform
well in front of the camera it's of no
use
for 45 years he has reflected and shaped
society when he got angry the nation got
angry
when he got injured the nation came to a
standstill and now when the common man
of the nation has taken to the streets
with enough he made shut yo grip what
you said was more an instigation by the
people who write firms and if credit has
to be given to the mood of the country
at the moment and how it is reflected in
cinema you will have to credit the
writers of the time so if you felt that
there was a moment in a film which
talked about anger which talked about
going against the system wanting to
fight alone
then salim-javed who wrote the script of
Xanadu at that point of time will have
to be credited because they were the
ones that thought about it and many a
times this question is supposed to me
but I'm I'm merely a you know another
actor who has just happened to be lucky
enough to get that role
you're not merely anything mr. Bachchan
yeah right now I am they came of a
turning point where
mainly due to financial reasons I got an
offer from television to host KBC which
was the Hindi version of Who Wants to Be
a Millionaire and I took that job and I
and I felt that there was a savior in
many respects because suddenly it gave
me an opportunity to interact with with
the people of the nation with with the
common man with people whom we knew
existed in our country but we'd never
known their conditions it was a great
eye opener for me apart from the fact
that it was a novel experience for me to
be working on television everyone said
that I was making the biggest mistake of
my life by going into television
reducing myself from a 70 millimeter
screen onto a 25 inch TV screen felt was
almost like reducing your stature to 25
inches of a TV screen but there were
compulsions and I went ahead and I'm now
in the 12th year of KBC I keep quoting
my father all the time and I'm sure I've
done this millions of times one of the
first things he taught me was Mankato HR
now the Dutch if things happen according
to how you wish that's good but if they
don't that's even better and I could
never understand that and when I asked
him he said if they're not happening
according to your wish
they're happening according to the wish
of some divine force and that divine
force will never think ill about you so
you have to respect that as being better
so if things what I said fine if they
didn't I felt that there was some kind
of divine force or divinity that didn't
want me to do that and perhaps wait for
another opportunity the other thing he
told me was when I was struggling a lot
in those times I said you know boss
Sanger said you and me
so he said Jeptha given health optics
I used to tell him you know that life is
a struggle and used to say so long as
there is life there is going to be
struggle I think if we accept this
factor that your life is never going to
be easy something or the other is going
to happen
so rather than and sit in some kind of
despondency on that and be aware that
tomorrow is another challenge is another
day which which could turn out to be
profitable which may not but eventually
there will be another day when you can
start trying all over again and then
there was a lag in your career for
almost 10 to 15 years which is really
the death of an actor because you join
politics then you made some bad
decisions then you didn't really sign
film and then suddenly you were a
middle-aged actor what did you do to
change the rules of the game that today
you are sitting here I think certain
circumstances arose at that point of
time where I was given to understand
that I didn't need to work anymore and I
took a sabbatical for a couple of years
and now that I look back I feel that
that was a mistake
and I shouldn't have done that because a
lot of water had flown under the bridge
so to say during the time that I wasn't
working it also it also teaches you that
you're never going to be the best you're
never going to be on top of the ladder
there's always be somebody who's going
to be younger better than you who will
take your place and this is quite common
in in sports and in our profession as
well and it takes a bit of time to
understand that I would be lying if I
said that I was not comfortable with it
it was very discomforting because you
suddenly find that if you go into a
public situation you find greater
attention being given to the other
person than yourself when all along your
or career you've been the center of
attraction and it takes a while to
understand that but I think that the
sooner you understand that the better of
you as an actor you're not going to be
able to be number one you're never going
to be able to attract the kind of
commercials or the public adulation and
you just want to carry on working
because you enjoy the profession without
all these other tributaries that get
attached to it I look for challenges
even today and even as I sit here I I
hope that tomorrow as I start a new firm
I will be able to look at it as a
challenge I am still very nervous when I
go there I I feel that every new
opportunity that comes my way it needs
to be looked at as that one door that
will open something which perhaps will
stop me from being bankrupt again and
stop me from getting back into that
situation where I have to plead for
against all my debtors to save me from
this situation and that's how I look at
it every day
I hope that I can continue doing that
because I don't want this sword this
democrates sword hanging on my head and
therefore I continue working so long as
I can but yes in the back of my mind
there will be those ugly moments that
plagued me and the fear of them
recurring again is perhaps what drives
me every day I will tell you you've said
this in the past that you are really a
directors actor that at the end of the
day you don't have an idea of the film
but you absorb the directors idea what
he expects a few yeah I think that it's
important for for you to leave the
decision-making to one person I'd like
to listen to one person on set and if
he's the captain of the ship I will do
what he asked me to do because he has
the visual and the sense and the the
idea in his mind of what he wants to
make
if you have a disagreement with him have
the disagreement during the time when he
is narrating the script you have all
your arguments and discussions before
that but when she come and said I think
it's only very professional and ethical
to follow what the director tells it to
do if this 71 year old mr. Bachchan
could go back to the younger amita's and
hold his hand and say don't take this
pass go here instead at what moment
would that feel I'd never say that
because I think that whatever happened I
wouldn't want to change it I feel that
many of the mishaps or the wrong
decisions or the failures that I had
were a great learning grass for me I
think I'm a lot wiser now no one is the
ultimate person as far as the wisdom is
concerned so I I feel that I wouldn't
want to change anything and just
continue the way I'm going thank you
guys so much for watching I made this
video because facts Gillian asked me to
so if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it
down the comments below and I'll see
what I can do
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from this video that really resonated
with you what point did you take home
the most what change you're going to
make in your life or your business after
watching this video please leave in the
comments below and I'm going to join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout out to Catherine Carini
Catherine thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book it really really
really means a lot to me so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love guys I'll see you soon